we're building some furniture today
we're building some furniture and it's
gonna be okay
will it be functional probably nuts wow
really ryx hello i'm destinee and i'm
lia and today we are making some
furniture sober and today we are making
furniture drunk drunk very very drugs i
build everything my whole living room
was built by me
I built my TV stand I built my bookshelf
I built my dresser I love to build I
literally am so confident this is there
gonna be a piece of piece of pie how do
you feel I am actually a little nervous
about this for the first time I was
going 1 to 10 I like at 8.5 really yeah
well I am lightweight 4 out of 5 now I'm
not a good 7 yeah I'm ready it's up in
the back do not know why Madeleine I
just like the smell one could be weird
it looks like it may be another bench
come with everything yeah one time I did
get furniture you had to put together
and they didn't send anything I
literally had my hairbrush it was like
bang in the nails and you dude you got
dude okay I can't you're good I can't
listen we got this oh this is easy doing
help flip it upside down no I got this
actually no no let me help you if you
need help please I'm here teamwork make
sure they're facing the right way though
cuz I've done that to where I've built
something and then I look up and it's
inside step 1 get the side step 1 is 2
steps do the two step it's literally two
parts get the leg okay oh look let's
skip to step two you so that if a little
the big holes have to be on the inside
why are we skipping cuz you got look if
you thought no but they're different
sizes that's the part doesn't matter
right now
that literally matters okay I can't I
don't know I think I did something wrong
okay we're on a roll misty we're doing
it we're doing it we're doing it okay
step one there this is pointing at
something it's pointing at the hole no
no no the screw this it's putting out
this mm-hmm this it's pointing it like
the bottom that's this careful this is a
weapon
yeah please you made me nervous you do
not need tools I do need to know let's
make me nervous why your energy like I
just I can see you swinging like a like
this please I am at very animated hey
bright oh wait just kidding reading is
very fundamental wow I didn't even read
the instructions
it's where that one right step one are
we at step one we have not made any
progress do you not to be all the pieces
sleep I think this is so embarrassing
so we can't figure this out so we're
only gonna do one right one let's just
work on one it could be mine pigby
you're let's just work on this one look
they're both undone so put one away I
can't help you you did things backwards
you didn't word just my holes don't
align oh wait I think I have a problem
too Maya this is like really off so yeah
the one with no hole goes in the back I
got I figured it up it's this one I was
right like I always am I'm just trying
to really make sure this thing yay Wow
there's no way please but us it's going
in look what Oh Zach
got it oh look at that
Oh twist going right on out so good okay
okay wait yeah I think yeah so else we
straight we do one more for good measure
okay might need a break we need a
fast-forward through break your both of
you both looks up there you know okay
let's see you're fired
Wow no no no that is not supposed to be
an angle that was your job to twist it
twist yeah believe is I'm on my last
twist you know mama D I'm trying so hard
throws me off look I'm almost done I got
one little thing in there I am sweating
yeah my piss is not worth the make up I
did my picture misty let me help you
boom I would never discover them boom
we're missing some pieces
no not wallah no she's not done you're
loose yeah what's going on up top up top
top there okay I'm done three down one
more screw to go destiny is out for the
count you did not do this right it's too
late we gotta keep going
that's me Wow
Wow yours turned out really good let me
help you do it okay do it all right let
me get on this contemporary it made
exactly this it's hard this needs to be
it like the mocha dad something's wrong
that was hard nine everyone do that
again you know that was difficult I'm
sweating when I do this again never
listen as the queen of furniture
I'm embarrassed this is bad what is it
it's firewood
[Music]
[Music]